Oh yes our children grew up with the children
around the area although we are about
six kilometres out of nimbin
and our children attended the copic camp
local school here donna our youngest girl
did go to newbern high school
and they were they played sport
and everything in nimbin with and against
the local or the alternate children
and there was no problems and i think
the children are the main thing
that we've got to look at for to assimilate
both groups into a better functioning
community.
Oh yeah there's been some low
points and hope oints ian.
Yeah some of the low points have been.
Some of the and a very small percentage.
I've got to emphasize of the alternate
are extremists and when it comes to.
Such a the local just lately
and the storage of just being in installed
now we've had great arguments against it.
I we've had community consultation
and unfortunately these extremist will not
accept a democratic vote in other words
a majority vote and i still
campaigning against it
and we've had the situation where one
of them's even said that when the cert
when the public toilet will be filled
with cement. When it is finished.
Oh that's some of the low
points but the high points are
when they alternate themselves are
taking part in community affairs
and i mean the community.
If air such as progress associations
ratepayers associations
and taking an active part in
the community affairs and
that is the biggest proportion of them
and they do not want
the extremists at all.
They would rather do without them and.
It is a situation where i think the high
point really outweigh the low points and.
I'm happy to be a member of the
newman community i can assure you.
Yes i
and i think that's probably one of the worst
situations of the disadvantages probably
of the aquarius first of all it's stigmatized
the village as a hippie capital of
australia. Not only the state and
that is something i don't think
that the community will ever live down.
It is something that as i mentioned
a while ago the alternative.
Don't even want that
stigmatized in that way.
I think the other down
want is the the drug scene
that did follow the aquarius best of all
and i suppose it can't all be blamed
on it but it's damp from that time
and it's a problem that's going
to take a lot to overcome it.
There are quite a few.
Achim organisations in the community at
the present stage campaigning with the
police and the local state
and federal government to try to do something
about it to clean it up the street
scene is not very very good at all
of the president stage and i think
that is the one bad thing really
that came from as well as dig my toes
asian it came from the queers festival
that it's going take a lot to live down.
Well it's got the image that
if you want an easy life
or something like you come
to newman it's there. And.
Oh.
I live far enough out of newman not to
be caught up in a too much as i said six
kilometres away but it is not good
on the street at the present stage
and i think the developers
that are developing around neumann at the
present stage are coming in contact with
this when they're trying
to sell properties
when they're trying to sell blocks for
building. They're coming against a.
A little bit of animosity or.
Rebellion would be the wrong word
against buying a block in nimbin
and that's one of the things that
i think it's got to be overcome
and it'll need a lot of work by the alternate
by the local community to overcome
all these problems
but i think it can be done.
Only the extremist not
wanting any change the.
The majority of the alternative side you
most certainly don't mind any great change
providing the environment is looked after
providing all the ordinances of the
council are abided by the doesn't
seem to be any problem with them
but there is a a section
and i said the the extremists don't want
any change whatever an even campaign at a
local auction or something like that
and tell people not to buy.
Probably the most things
that i've had complaints against
the the extremists i would be the
situation with multiple
occupancies on properties
and on my time on council that
i've had. Lots of problems.
I've got nothing against
multiple occupancy. At all.
Providing
that they have got community titles
providing all the ordinance of counsellor
abided by
and all the recommendations laid down for
fire control for environment control are
abided by exactly the same as any
other developers required to do that.
Unfortunately has not been done by a lot
of the multiple occupancy in the area.
Now there are. In the police
district 67 multiple occupancies.
They're not all legal some have been done
the council don't even know anything
about them.
So we've got a real big problem as far as
multiboot i couldn't read a concern some
of which are legal and
some of which are working
and functioning exceptionally well and
i've got no problem with them at all
but i certainly have a
problem with any of the ones
that are not abiding by counseled ordinances.
They're building codes. They held.
Provisions for the for the safeguard
of the environment of the community.
Well history need multiple i can
go right away back to 1973 74.
When a tunnel falls coordination cooperative
come into being with the drainage i
counsel it will the first one on the i think
the whole of the north east corner at
least of the state of new south wales
and it was like a guinea pig and.
I have being a councillor on the council
that time had a job to
come to grips with it and.
It got off the ground not unanimous vote
by the sticks councillors on the council
but the main thing that swayed do
majority of the council were they said
that they want to do their own
thing and look after themselves.
Don't take any part in community
affairs and have no problem.
They're and they want to do their
own thing and get all that old.
Now that's why the whole
council not the whole council
but the majority of council
to vote to let it go ahead.
Since that time we've had a history of
multiple occupancy and. The council.
It has been fragmented. A whole lot
there's been a legal buildings go up.
There's been threats of of taking
them down with the bulldozer.
We have the ombudsman it step in
a couple of occasions we've had.
Ministers of the state stepping
in on terrible occasions
and there have not been a
good liaison between building
codes health regulations
with multiple occupancies
and with the councils even now the lismore
city council which has an effect.
Most of these multiple occupancy it.
I suppose one of the worst examples i can
think of at the present stage have been
quite a few but one of the
worst examples was over it.
To remain here creek
and i think i'm right in our wallets a
road i'm sorry that's the one we had a lot
of problems over there and one
and we even had about three council
inspections with all aldermen
and administration staff and we
just could not get off the ground
but we tried to force the ordinances
on them and the ombudsman
and other ministers of state stepped in
and stopped as doing anything real
thing about that. What i feel that.
It has not been a good thing as far
as state and local government.
Relationships are concerned
when they wouldn't back the local government
up in we were trying to rectify a
problem that was caused by a
multiple occupancy development.
Illegal buildings they not
even a development application
or a building up like a can put into council
they had houses resting on logs on the
ground that they've fallen in the forest.
They had houses built in the forest
which i suppose at least a metre of
material that combustion material
that would burn at the you know.
The least thing to started off and we
just couldn't get into their heads
that they needed protection they had no
protection themselves they expected the
council to provide everything that
some of the really bad cases.
All them have not been that bad.
Bodie farm and the other one.
Of course the other side of it.
That was the argument ian.
And most certainly that lent a lot
of weight to had the concession
that the council that they
got away with council.
But i don't believe
that they should be treated any
other different to any other one.
They've got to abide by the regulations
and most certainly the regulations
regarding multiply communities
or these type of building
most certainly is lower.
So i feel it lowered
and then the other building for any other
development developing in the community.
No they shouldn't be treated any
differently at all like in other words
irrespective of what the building
conditions are if they agree to
that they must do it.
And unfortunately they go ahead
and put a put a building up
that doesn't conform in any.
Shape or form and then we've got
well the council has big problems
and whether they can pull
it down or knock it down
and we've seen to a very
very not in this council
but in the local in the neighbouring
council of cairo go where they've had the
pre-teen and there's been very
very big unrest over in three
or four day programme
of pulling houses apart
and i'd hate to see our
council having to do that.
It is a very drastic measure
but however i believe
that they bring it on themselves
when they don't by abide like they greta
in the first place to get a development
and then when they get the
development they go ahead
and do whatever they want to do and
that is wrong.
Way.
Yes but he and i agree what you
say but however they've been here
and they're they're not causing any
problems. For anyone else either.
And they are some of them are taking
part in the community affairs
and helping to shape the community
they would like to see it done and
that i'd like to see them all doing
instead of the extremists getting out
and laying down in front of bulldozers or.
Chainsaws or something to
that effect.
Yeah some of the buildings that we inspected
left i helluva lot to be desired.
There and i'll pick reason i'll
bales and even cream sheds
and things like it to start at all
four and they were slapped up.
By a bit of blue plastic
and stuff like that.
The only only thing they had from
weatherboard but they'd be the worst ones.
There were the others that.
Almost would conform to
building regulations
but they never ever got
permission to do it and
that was a problem they didn't want to
get permission they just went ahead.
But if they had of went ahead there their
house would have been been able to be.
To be modified without any real great
effort on their part to make it
fit the building codes and
that what they didn't do.
Oh you can hear the local
policeman was called down to the.
Showground to go.
Talk to a fellow or put a follow in
that was causing a disturbance at the
local show or up to the local show
and he would have had to have a bottle
of tequila and a bottle of scotch and
and about a keg of beer to get
in the condition he was in
and he was running around
brandishing a acts in his hand.
So anyway the local policeman you had was
so he got about three more police to come
out to lismore and they went down. And.
The local police and even the only
went up to him and he said come on it.
I've got to take you up to the
police station. If that's alright.
He said it'd take me in and so any mate at
all. I bet i'd try to him a little bit.
So he pulled his baton and
he hit him across the knee
that usually brings them down on their knees
pretty quickly this violent ever even
turned a muscle.
So he put the matter need other
hand hit him across the other night
and they looked at his look
made he said if i were you.
He did i put that away before
i do something with it.
And he did it.
In every field anything.
I know he was a.
Call in and i used to call him
the indian indian something.
He was a big man they reckon he'd take about
three bottles of the keel of the game
in. That's made any run longstreet
with the accent right now let everyone
but never hurt anyone. But the local
people didn't like him at all.
He thought the danger
though the your concern.
So he put the baton back in the thing like
an act impolitely to get in the in the
van which he did.
I suppose one of the great characters
and you'll probably interviewing him.
The fellow called harry
anything. Harry is.
Comes from tunnel ford coordination
co-operative he's been there since 1970 273
harry was always very thin
and we always thought
that harry would never
see the next winter.
Out but harry and we to go in the truck
driver because used to drive there.
The truck that used to go to brisbane
bring back their supplies of vegetables
and stuff. However we all didn't see
the next winter out each year that
when part with all the next winter.
We'll get him. However how anything is.
I think he's president of the progress
association of the president stage he does a
lot for community affairs he does a lot
for people in sport and helps kids
and money mother and to my
knowledge harry did not married
and i can assure you with one
fine gentleman with harry any
but he had one of the old identities
of nimbin that that everyone and him
and liked in appreciates he's a tremendous
fellow he looked up to everyone in him.